let me jump to the story uh from twitter
actually they have this running in their
what's happening uh tab and it
exemplifies perfectly that the civil war
may actually be people of cognitive
ability and people of limited cognitive
ability
because this twitter says manipulated
image of fundraising email from former
president trump contained fake nuclear
codes fact checkers report
if you needed a fact checker to tell you
that donald trump did not email the
nuclear codes to people then you are in
the uh latter faction i have just
mentioned this is actually quite amazing
let me let me pull this up from newsweek
because there's a very prominent leftist
podcast i guess i think mueller she
wrote as the left podcast new
donald is fundraising by giving us
nuclear codes this is an effing joke to
him and i i know
they understand trump is is is doing a
gag but this is not even real they they
they thought
they believed it
they didn't believe that trump was
actually getting out nuclear codes but
this is a meme
the new codes are 15 25 50 80. can i
count on you to donate
twenty five dollars fifty dollars eighty
dollars
if you make it recurring we can nuke
beijing tonight is this like not
realizing someone photoshopped that and
then put it out or is it not realizing
it was a joke no because a manipulated
image no i i know i could tell you that
that's a manipulated image because
that's not what trump fundraising emails
look like have you seen these yeah
they're all saying the fbi is coming for
you give me money yeah they're all like
they're all like what is wrong with you
why haven't you why haven't you signed
in yet for this month why haven't you
this these high pressure tactics and i
don't know why but for some reason it's
it's it's actually it's it's gross it's
actually gross i'm not a fan and i don't
i don't like it
i need to stop it i get i get
fundraising emails from from some and
it's like unpaid balance yeah i'm just
like dude
it's crazy yeah they're just like and
you realize that they're just preying on
certain people they're just straight up
praying on people it's just it's just
i'll tell you what's crazy
independent fox news airs edited photo
of trump raid judge with gillane maxwell
because they can't just say meme edited
photo
it says what i mean to say
and was fox news making a gag is that
what was happening well i do want to
point out here that
they didn't edit in the the easy time
and the oreos that's an actual those are
actually in the photo of the epstein
judge um that's actually real that's
obviously actually glenn maxwell but in
reality this is a photo of epstein and
her rubbing epstein's feet what they've
done here is take out epstein i guess
his torso and replace that with the
judge that was epstein's lawyer that
before was epstein's prosecutor and then
yeah hannity says i think it's actually
a picture of jeffrey epstein with
somebody putting the judge's head on
there i'm guessing i don't know no it's
not just his head that's the point
though no but but on fox news they
weren't saying like look at this
stunning image of the judge they were
like look at this photo is that that's
hannity i'm sorry he's like that's
epstein isn't it okay so right so kill
me was um i didn't actually watch it but
from the article it looks like because
kilmeade was hosting for guest hosting
for tucker yeah um and tulsi gets hosted
the night before
oh wow and um and in the handoff
killmead is keeping the joke going so
he's saying i don't know that looks like
the plane that uh that looks like it you
know and and he's doing his whole well
i'm sorry but when hannity was like you
know i used to say it was 99 of the fbi
was good but maybe that's down to 95
come on man still saying that 95 he just
said it this week 95 of the dude take
off the cia pin just come on man did you
see the uh jimmy door nina turner thing
oh yeah and that was the brand of joy
gray thing so for those that aren't
familiar you've got the jimmy dore thing
jimmy dore is basically saying
if the right is now coming out and
saying the fbi is corrupt we should
embrace that and say yes thank you
welcome to the fight
and i'm like exactly and then you have
bran i think it's brandon joy gray on
she's on the hill right yeah she said
basically the same thing that we all
think the fbi is corrupt if the right is
not saying the same thing we've won like
okay let's move forward
right yeah but then you had nina turner
who was like
just ragging on jimmy calling him you
know what right wing and racist or
whatever see i used to like nina turner
because she used to call out like the
joe biden democrats back in the day kind
of from the um from the bernie sanders
camp and then it seems like which he has
like some show now or something and
and now she just won't do that she was
responding to jimmy maybe we can pull up
this uh twitter thread at some point and
with identitarian politics like
uh something about jimmy's attacking a
black woman yeah black woman i'm a woman
but when you look at the full thread
jimmy started that by saying a leftist
something something something so he
identified yeah he played identity
politics jimmy jimmy she responded with
it jimmy pointing out that the left has
typically been anti-fbi but now aren't
is different from saying you attacked me
because of my race but that's
identitarian calling someone leftist
like when you start off a conversation
with them it's not yeah it is you're
you're making giving them an identity
and that's that's no he's saying like
that's their position like you have to
be able to say like a group of people
he's not saying you're a terrible lefty
because you think that like well i'm not
bringing in her criticism of it it's not
you're you're identifying them as a part
of a group but that's not that's not
what identification is
identitarian is identity-based
governance right well i mean you could
have identitarian governance or you
could just have identitarianism
all the black shirts all the gray shirts
that's ideological that's the identity
and i would just strongly recommend
you just look up what editorialism is
because you are just absolutely you're
talking about like big eye
identitarianism governance is that what
you're talking about because you can be
an identitarianist without being
involved in politics
okay identitarian specifically refers to
the physical attributes of identity and
governance based on such saying
someone's of the last or mental i mean
mental attributes physical and mental
attributes yeah what you identify as so
it typically refers to like yeah see
identitarianism is a pan-european
nationalist far-right political algebra
i'm not talking about the political
ideology now you're reading the
politicized like left argument the big
eye the big eye identitarianism movement
okay apparently that's a real movement
uh this is a anyway anyway jimmy started
off by calling her a leftist which is
not identity which is not i that's just
political wholly disagree with you guys
but you're wrong what you're saying is
like if i were to say the entire state
of wisconsin has been calling for years
to defund the fbi that would be like
saying that's identitarianism which it's
not wisconsinites yeah and
anti-wisconsinites understand no
wisconsin is yours like the entire state
i love wisconsin by the way cheese baby
that's right if i was like all the
ladies you get stand up that's
identitarianism no
of course it is you're judging someone
by a piece of their identity judging
them it's just saying this group of
people it's just
i think i think you're mixing up
identitarianism with just identifying
yeah i don't think the verb of
identifying vegetarian is identity plus
government right well you're talking
about the big eye movement no that is a
moment no no no no that's what the word
means you're gonna have to pull that up
and show me definition wise because i i
just i don't i would encourage you to
research this before making a political
point that doesn't it i'm not making a
political issue was that jimmy dore said
she used the lowest like the lowest of
identity politics to attack him because
he said the left has always opposed the
fbi
we should be embracing the right when
they say this like you know and brennan
joy grace said marjorie taylor green is
right and i'm like here here sounds like
sounds like some some logic and some
more moral principles to me and then
nina turner was just like jimmy dore is
insulting well this is black woman this
is the dynamic you see you've seen
between like magga and the left and sort
of like the populist left for so many
times because it's always like you'll
get a couple a couple people from both
sides start flirting with one another
and then other and then you'll have
people like jimmy dora come along and
say hey wait a minute we agree with what
you're saying or hawk newsome when he
when he got up at the maga rally
was like the mother of all rallies in dc
i think it was 2018. i was there and he
said look you guys are against corrupt
politicians we're against corrupt cops
could you agree with us on that and
people started cheering said yeah of
course right and so you'll have these
moments where people start kind of
flirting with each other in sort of the
two populist camps and then along will
come somebody from the establishment or
doing the work of the establishment and
saying hey you guys need to break that
up right now yeah but it it tends to be
that um
like nina turner in this instance right
as the establishment you're concerned
trolling you're straight up concerned
trolling but the problem is
you you end up with people who embrace
like on the left they they end up
believing this nonsense like the nuclear
documents thing was widely believed by
these p these establishment shills and
it just it was not true or to the extent
that was that true is the search warrant
was it was broad it was for literally
all documents so to claim they were
looking for nuclear documents okay i can
argue they're looking for dogs the
document said anything relating to
trump's presidency so i could have
written a story saying the fbi was
searching for information about the cats
that trump had talked about well yeah
because i'm sure at some point he did
and it's in the record somewhere he
mentioned a cat that's a stupid story
it's nonsense they all believe it and
i'm just sitting there and i'm like
these are the people who believe jesse
smallette
okay i don't take my political cues from
them and that's so when when you get the
two populist factions and they're like
hey we agree on these things and then
all of a sudden an establishment person
comes up to break it up and they say
something nonsensical like justice
millet and the left believes it
it's like okay dude look we're kind of
like i don't know how you bring the
sides together when you've got one side
who's gonna believe that or kind of like
when you had a cv show on cnn called
crossfire where
uh tucker carlson and somebody from the
left could sit down and argue but at
least they were talking that was that
was that cnn i believe was cnn wow and
then jon stewart comes on and starts
yelling at both of them for having a
discussion and then 20 years later
somebody has to go and confront jon
stewart in the street and say john if
you want this burn pits bill done we got
to work together will you shake my hand
and he did yeah he was yelling at you
that was crazy he was not happy with me
at first what did you say to him that
the first thing he said like what did
you say to him i said you're short i
said no i did not say it was short i
didn't i didn't attack him i didn't
tucker did
tucker said many things about it but but
tucker and he have a different history
than he and i do um it i'd never met him
before and
you know the jon stewart thing
was i went up to him and yeah i was
recording but i was not live
and i just wanted to have a record for
so that you know nobody could accuse me
of doing something i didn't do and
raheem kassam was there and
i said look you're you're attacking and
smearing all the republicans as being
against this burn pit bill you're saying
you're against the republicans and the
context is this there's this there was
and it has been passed now and signed
into law
this bill for benefits for for veterans
who were injured by the burn pits and
the burn pits
were funny enough classified material um
was being burned because when you're not
the president you have to dispose of
this but if you're in the field you know
it's not like you can follow some
specific process you just got to get rid
of it and then move on so hence burn
pits um i had people even in my unit
that would come back from afghan girl i
knew came back from afghanistan um
because of the black smoke that would
come out of this stuff
nails started falling out fingernails
toenails hair was coming out in clumps
just you know it does stuff to your head
i've got another buddy who's had issues
with his um his lungs you know if he
goes over a certain altitude he has
trouble finding flying on airplanes and
stuff so burn it's bad very bad but jon
stewart was running around at first
doing this huge media tour saying
republicans hate the vets republicans
hate the vets and that's why they won't
vote for this thing when in reality if
you look what the republicans were
saying people like ted cruz and and pat
to him not even a fan of pat toomey um
he's my senator right and they were
saying look well the cbo score came back
and said you know there's this 400
billion dollar discrepancy between the
house and the senate bills and we want
to deal with that right and
that's not what sort was saying and so i
went to him and i said look john you're
so close on getting this bill done will
you sit down and meet with ted cruz or
any of these guys maybe i can even help
facilitate that with you know whatever
phone numbers i have in my rolodex to
make that happen and i don't think he
heard me because he saw me and he you
know recognized me and was like oh well
this is that guy from twitter that
doesn't like me so he just went off he
just started completely going off
and that's what you saw on cnn
and then
later on what was really interesting
though is and to his credit right i
stayed back i talked a bunch of people
tim jensen dude from um grunt style we
chatted for a while and then john saw us
talking and said well hey i like this
guy and if he likes jack maybe i can go
talk to him so jon stewart comes back up
to me
and has this guy said hey man i'm sorry
about that you know i thought you were
trolling me i wasn't really listening to
what you were saying i was just kind of
responding to what i thought you were
saying
and you know if you want to work
together to get this bill done let's do
it i said that's great john and you said
that to me now in person
but before you said all that stuff on
camera so would you do a video with me
so that people can understand that we're
going to work together and he did to his
credit he did this this is the problem
right here can we pull this up
ground.news jon stewart's bias oh this
is perfect 59 left it's not all that bad
i mean john uh uh does get some
conservative some some right-leaning
news in there he goes on fox he goes on
newsmax and um and uh he praised trump
when he when trump was it was the 911
first responders i believe trump was
working on getting relief he's talked
about um the the wuhan lab he's talked
about that oh yeah yeah yeah so i think
i think it's really interesting that you
can see the integrity of an individual
in their bias fact checker
isn't that fascinating yeah john stewart
it's like he yelled at you abruptly and
then you had to break through that
barrier but you guys eventually shook
hands and found something there we did
and it's like
you look at his biased blind spotter on
ground news and
59 left leaning
and his attitude and behavior is like 59
left leaning you know what i mean just
enough to let it go right right just
enough where he like actually does pull
back a little bit and have that
conversation with you
i was looking at a tweet from uh
stephen marsh we've had on the show he's
the guy who wrote the book the uh the
next civil war i think it's called
and he said something to the effect of
like
being pro-police but anti-fbi how will
the right phrase this one and then i
sent him a link to an article and i'm
like the right has been ragging on
police since covent right yeah no covid
and then when the churches and all right
yeah and then i showed him his blind his
blind spot or bias it's like 80 percent
left no conservative news like bro get
out of your bubble
it invariably when i see these people
saying these things that are just wrong
wrong wrong
they're always their media consumption
is always dominated by the law do you
think moderate is also a bubble because
mine is like 80 white 80 moderate or
something like that and i wonder if i'm
in a bubble as well because no you're
just outside of politics well doesn't
this also
so
mine's totally skewed right because
i work with post-millennial and human
events so i'm sharing their events their
articles said the same thing right right
right
that doesn't mean that's the only thing
i'm reading no of course of course yeah
it's not perfect so it you know i feel
like it's kind of skewed so yeah i'm
posting that and right you see postman i
know human events are my top three
sources but in many cases i'm either
editing those articles or working on
those articles and yeah you're
definitely going to be biased towards
ones that i uh hey look at that hey very
nice look at you oh no look at that left
look at you left this look at you
leftist that's what is this
tim cass is a top three news source all
right and tribal i don't know
no my top source is tim cast
but no i'm saying for you as a person is
that your top news source
um
a little bit but i wouldn't say top i
don't know if i have a top news source i
was thinking it may be twitter and
that's right can you consider twitter a
news source
should be your top news it's a really
great site i actually
too slow for me
like but it is that's why i'm posting
stories no i actually think this so
somebody asked me this once uh as an in
an interview and they said what's your
top news source and i just said i don't
have a top news source i follow topics
and they didn't know what i meant i was
like well if i just see something
trending or if there's something i'm
interested in i just type it into the
search bar on twitter and i see what's
going on so if i want to know about you
know the like there's a whole mexican
cartel war going on right now down in
jalisco then
hardly it's never trending but you can
just go to twitter right now and type it
in and go watch a bunch of videos from
it um people getting shot up in little
caesars and
just just crazy crazy video auto zone
but it's not but i'm not sharing it it
just happens to be something i'm
interested in because it's crazy citizen
journalists is it usually people with
like a lot of it citizen journalists
yeah and and so my point being though is
that i'm not going to an outlet for that
i'm just following it on twitter i was
thinking lately last time maybe twitter
is an outlet because i'll even see in
like news articles they'll quote twitter
posts section 230 baby and they're but
yeah but they're like un inhibited they
can do whatever they want they can guide
the news they can say this story is not
gonna show up on twitter uh if you
search for it this one's gonna go to the
top of the algorithm twitter is a source
because there's tons of journalists that
are just on twitter
exactly so i follow a bunch of people
that are like field reporters and stuff
like that they're on twitter i get
breaking news because i'm on that
platform but this doesn't show twitter
but that doesn't show that right
mediapoly
oh right it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't show who you follow and things
it shows you
based on i think there's a couple
different organizations that rate the
leaning of various news organizations
and then they ground news applies that
to their blind spotter or whatever but
um i think if you were to even look at
my bias 40 left 25 center 27 right i
think most people probably agree with
that in how i act you know what i mean
that is pretty close for you right right
right like not die hard trumper but
sometimes being like well you know i
don't know right yeah yeah i got a hard
time
like pegging down your political
things you just seem kind of like
general but i mean you talk more about
people what you would consider on the
right or in the conservative movement
for whatever reason i don't know but
like it's more interesting is that
because of where you found yourself in
life or or um was it easier to work with
people like that what what kind of
pushed you in that direction you know i
don't know i mean like
i'm i mean i'm catholic that's kind of
where i come from but that has nothing
to do with my my news um that's also one
of the reasons that i think that you
know sort of the
the libertarian movement while it seemed
interesting to me i could never quite
could never quite you know go fully into
it because that's just not where i come
from um
and
when i look at you know when i look at
people on the right and really 2016 just
kind of blew that up and at that point
it wasn't even about right or left it
was just who's telling the truth right
who's actually just just going up there
and saying you know is this a movement
of the people versus dc or is it you
know is it uh is it just a typical
election of left versus right and where
you are getting no obviously not right
you know this is a populist movement and
that's the side i'm always going to be
on i got really turned off by the
democratic establishment after 2016.
that was hard to watch what they did to
bernie sanders yeah so we went we would
go out there at the dnc with jill stein
with the bernie people and we covered
all that stuff and i covered that with
just as much attention as i did anything
on the right too thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you